people are worried about Sentinels and
that's because we found out they're
burning and eye-watering 700
000 a month on salaries and other
expenses but is this a cause for concern
and are they that much worse off than a
lot of other Esports teams a little
funny that in an 80-page document one
sentence in that document has become the
uh exciting element of Twitter this
morning
quick reminder that liking the video If
you have a good time today as well as
subscribing to the channel and ringing
the notification Bell are great ways to
help us out and let us know that you're
enjoying the content cheers
so last week Hunter pointed out on
Twitter on August 5th that a Sentinels
crowdfunding campaign showed exactly the
amount of time that the company would be
able to operate based on the outcome of
said campaign he also linked to the
document so you can check it out
yourself if you like we'll link to it in
the description as well also thanks for
letting me oink it so basically if
Sentinels were to make the minimum
fundraising amount in this campaign but
then received no further investment of
any kind they say they'd be able to
operate for about two to three months if
they hit the maximum that they're
seeking in this campaign but again
receive no further investment from any
Source they could go for four to five
months this document has a lot of
interesting information in it so feel
free to check it out on your own time if
you're a nerd like me but basically the
point of it is to inform people who are
potentially going to be investing in
Sentinels about some of the the pitfalls
and risks that could be associated with
doing that but listen of course people
absolutely honed in on the fact that
this document said that Sentinels could
fail in months if they couldn't get
further funding content creators and
Esports personalities weighed in some
jokingly others trying to parse this
thing and listen a big part of the
discussion was that thing I mentioned
earlier Sentinels are in the red to the
tune of nearly seven hundred thousand
dollars a month now that is a lot of
money no question but how abnormal is it
really that's where the discussion went
with Genji CEO Arnold explaining that
this is very normal in Esports at least
right now but that doesn't mean it's
good or that it can stay this way long
term if you have been paying attention
recently you know that things in Esports
aren't exactly great from a financial
point of view the
urn and simultaneous cryptocurrency
Reckoning have left a lot of teams
looking for news sources of revenue at
the same time costs continue to rise and
maybe nowhere is this more true than
invalid where the game is grabbing hold
of a new generation of players so teams
have a massive interest in staying front
and center but to do that they need to
keep spending this is maybe doubly true
for Sentinels but it wasn't always that
way back before buga won the fortnite
World Cup Sentinels was trying to find a
path to building a legacy in Esports now
because of their valorant team they
undoubtedly have one the question is how
to fund that now and the answers aren't
clear so the crowdfunding campaign
that's being described in that document
is actually selling shares of the
company so this isn't your average
Kickstarter or something at the same
time the value of those shares is not
clear something the document explicitly
says it's possible the company could be
sold and that price might not align with
what you paid for the shares it's
possible that the company eventually
goes public we don't know so as a result
of all that uncertainty this document
talks about the risks inherent to
investing in Sentinels ultimately the
numbers are what everybody got fixated
on especially the two to three months or
four to five months so according to
Sentinel CEO Rob Moore those numbers are
accurate but what they show you is the
amount of time the company could operate
barring any further investment of any
kind the crowdfunding only raised this
much money and
Sentinels were not able to raise capital
from their current investors or any
other outside Equity Source then this is
how much Capital they would have it
doesn't say that the current investors
aren't going to continue to fund Moore
posted this interview to YouTube to kind
of explain what people were seeing in
the document and his point is
essentially this the two to three or
four to five month numbers they're only
hypothetical numbers in the event that
Sentinels could raise zero more dollars
besides the crowdfunding amount so let's
be Crystal on this this is a
hypothetical situation and it could
happen but it is not accurate to say
that without this crowdfunding Sentinels
is definitely shutting down in two to
three months or four to five months or
whatever and if you've seen someone
saying that they just got a little bit
mixed up these inclusions as CEO Rob
Moore points out are also a mandatory
part of SEC filings yes the key is this
is a filing with the SEC and and the
rules require
mandatory disclosures of potential risks
this is all about making sure that
investors have as much information as
possible when they make a decision now
you're all pretty smart so you probably
see where I'm about to go with this this
number exists for every company in
Esports that isn't profitable right now
right any team that's losing money right
now has a certain amount of Reserve
money that they can draw on and could
potentially get further investment if
they can find people who are interested
what this figure isn't saying is that
Sentinels is definitely shutting down
that seven hundred thousand dollars a
month in the red being spent on salaries
and merge acquisition could maybe still
be criticized though especially when as
Rich points out here you don't even have
teams in League of Legends
Counter-Strike or OverWatch but Moore's
answer to this question seems to be
simply that as a newcomer in the space
you have to be willing to spend money to
reach fans we didn't have the reach of
our competitors so if you're a sponsor
and you want to reach Esports fans and
we had a fraction of their reach well we
certainly weren't going to be one of
your top starting points Moore has also
argued that his competitors have had far
more time to raise Capital before
Sentinels did and I'd add that they
raised it in Far More favorable economic
conditions so according to more it's all
about getting the brain in front of
eyeballs for Sentinels that meant high
profile players and their salaries it
meant big bios it meant signing content
creators like Tarik it meant doubling
down on their own in-house content team
and as someone that watches way more
team content than probably anyone
watching this video I'm gonna tell you
that theirs is some of the best I'm a
little biased because their VP of
content is a former co-worker but I know
that they absolutely know their sh
listen for Sentinels right now they have
one thing that every team in Esports
wants fans who actually give a
about the award like in 2022
on Twitter we had the most engagement of
a North American Esports org now I'm not
saying that that justifies spending on
this exact scale no one's perfect people
make mistakes seven hundred thousand
dollars is a lot of bread but Moore's
argument is basically
you gotta pay to play one final point of
consideration then is whether Sentinels
actually can raise money outside of the
crowdfunding campaign and while I don't
have the real answer to that because I
don't work for Sentinels more seems to
claim in the video that the people who
are already invested aren't planning on
just cutting and running you know we've
raised Capital internally our investor
group is very committed to the strategy
that we have
and the intention is that we will
continue to provide funding for the
operation but the fact that this appears
in the document allows for the
hypothetical possibility and in an
uncertain Esports world like ours right
now it's probably unsurprising that that
was enough to get people chatting listen
it's tempting to treat Sentinels like
some kind of Bellwether if they can't
succeed with all of the prominence
they've had in a hot new esport who can
I wouldn't go that far because I don't
know exactly how much of that 8 million
dollars they lost last year was due to
changing conditions bad calls I don't
know maybe they misplayed it maybe they
didn't so even if that initial Panic was
a little misplaced I think the
crowdfunding effort brought up some
understandable concerns you can bet
we'll be following this one
I do I do have a Ben and Jerry's
addiction
I do want to be fully transparent that I
absolutely slammed a Ben a Ben and
Jerry's like chocolate brownie last
night it was so good it was so
good that's why I can't be CEO of an
Esports company man I just have a fridge
in my office and it would just be filled
with ice cream